well I am joined now by Noah and Lana
thank you guys so much for being here
and for doing this you both look very
cozy in your hoodies so you guys are
doing this awesome event a to all the
boys I've loved before table read slash
this amazing event featuring really
important speakers and it's all going to
raise money for the black lives matter
movement to fight racial inequality how
did you come up with the idea for this
because it is for an amazing cause and I
guarantee you you're her incredible fan
base is gonna show up for a table read
so how did you put the two together
thank you know like a lot of people
we're just asking ourselves like how can
we do our part help because we're coming
from a place of at least for me I felt
like I was coming from a place of
ignorance and and a lot of it was just
what can I do to help and Lana and I
have always been I think bonded by the
fact that yeah we're actors but we also
like Lana has a charity as well that she
represents and I think I think it kind
of just came about as this conversation
we were having and we thought why not
try I think to what Noah just said is I
have a scholarship with the Asia
Foundation that puts Vietnamese girls
through four years of high school
education and while we were actually
while we were shooting the sequel for
tava boys and doing press Noah and I
have always been close but we really
bonded over like whoa I'm doing this
thing for my girls that I love and Noah
is doing this amazing thing with
favorite names and and it's a passion
that we both both have and we kind of
really bonded over that and and then
obviously seeing everything that's been
happening right now in the world and
knowing that we have a voice in knowing
that we need to share it and use it like
watching Noah watching Noah make he
really is like the person who brought
all of this together for our table read
and for favorite Nations and for
everything and he has worked so so hard
and given his all to to the table read
but more than that
we're just the initiative in general and
so watching him do it is so amazing it's
been such a pleasure and honor for me to
even just be a small part of that of it
with him because I just feel like I'm so
proud of you Noah and I'm so proud of
the the platform that you're wielding
for good I think is so amazing and yeah
so obviously it's like who are we if we
don't use our platform right like I I
heard something really what so
beautifully said that was like people
follow you because they believe in you
so you have to show them what you
believe in and that really struck me
like oh wow this is exactly what I'm
trying to do with my girls and what I
try to do on my popcorns but Noah's
really taking it to like this next level
of you know gathering the funds to to
support these different organizations
and whatnot so yeah it's it's been such
an awesome pleasure to be able to work
on this together
but uh you you are so kind
what I love about every time I talk to
you guys you're each other's biggest
cheerleaders but then you both get so
humble when the other person is so
you're like complimenting shy compliment
[Music]